apprendre à synchroniser ses mouvements
pour pagayer un exercice pas si évident
pour paul du haut de ses 6 ans il
s'essaie au kayak en compagnie d'une
camarade de classe qui guetterait bien
canoë kayak à droite on a pu faire du
canoë kayak une belle initiation et
pourquoi pas l'année prochaine entrée au
club et du secourisme bien sûr apprendre
les gestes qui sauvent la pls et puis le
massage cardiaque
même pour des petites six ans et demi
c'est quand même extraordinaire de leur
enseigner ces gestes qui peuvent sauver
des vies plusieurs activités mises en
place par la fédération française de
natation
une dixième édition de la nuit de l'eau
au profit de l'unicef
cette année les fonds récoltés serviront
à soutenir l'accès à l'eau potable à
haïti haïti qui vous le savez a été
frappé par un ouragan terrible en
octobre dernier l'ouragan matthews de
nombreuses écoles ont été détruites mais
également tout le réseau d'adduction
d'eau a été endommagée tant et si bien
qu'aujourd'hui et bien les les haïtiens
et les enfants en particulier n'ont pas
un accès à une eau de bonne qualité et
en conséquence de quoi attrape de plus
en plus de maladies aujourd'hui encore
plus de 600 mille enfants sont en
difficulté à haïti dans les yvelines
quatre piscines ont participé à
l'événement ce type de journée peut
permettre de récolter 2000 euros par
manifestation mais la solidarité ne
s'arrête pas à la fin de la nuit de
l'eau l'unicef continue de récolter des
dons pour haïti sur son site internet